today we are going to look at an amazing
new AI system that can perform four
tricks the first is cool the second is
great the third one is simply incredible
to the point that I couldn't believe the
results and had to look over and over
again and the fourth is a thing of
beauty so what are the tricks first this
work is called gig again and it can
perform text to image we fellow Scholars
have seen this before many many times
you enter a text prompt and it paints
you an image what is great about it is
that it can give us reasonably high
quality images that is okay but here is
the kicker it can perform this in a
fraction of a second that is extremely
quick for instance the previous stargan
based method that could be roughly as
fast we needed to make significant
concessions in terms of quality not
anymore loving it two it is not only
fast but it is so fast that it can
create several images per second and
thus it offers a controllable latent
space this is a Hallmark for Gan based
methods and leads to incredible artistic
controllability as you see here but what
does all this mean a gun based method
means a generative adversarial Network
where two neural networks battle each
other one tries to generate new images
to fool the other one while the other
one trains to be able to spot these
synthetic images over time they battle
each other and they improve together now
third and this is where things get out
of hand super resolution or in other
words image upscaling here a course
image goes in and the AI guesses what
this image could be and synthesizes a
new really detailed image now hold on to
your papers and look at that the
difference can be really huge up to a
thousand times more pixels in the no
image so how does it compare to previous
methods for instance the amazing stable
diffusion oh my look at that it is so
much better across the board pretty much
everywhere but the eyes the eyes are
truly something else with the new
technique what a time to be alive and
finally fourth it also offers a
disentangled latent space for
controllability now I hear you asking
doctor what does that mean this means
that we can control the style in place
with the text prompt so whenever we get
a teddy bear that we really like but we
would like to see it crocheted a bit
fluffier or made of denim we can do that
but without generating a new teddy bear
all the changes are applied to the same
subject that is incredible I also loved
the ball example here this almost looks
like an image straight out of a material
modeling paper in computer graphics so
cool and what I absolutely love about
this paper is that normally for these
four problems we would need four
separate tools not anymore today we are
getting all of these amazing
capabilities with just one tool that can
do all of them and not only that but it
is so much faster than previous methods
while it is still competitive in terms
of visual quality it is not the best and
fastest at the same time not even close
but this trade-off is I think an amazing
value proposition if you enjoyed this
paper make sure to subscribe and hit the
Bell icon to not miss out we have some
more amazing papers coming up soon and
this video has been supported by weights
and biases look at this they have a
great Community Forum that aims to make
you the best machine learning engineer
you can be you see I always get messages
from you fellow Scholars tell telling me
that you have been inspired by the
series but don't really know where to
start and here it is in this forum you
can share your projects ask for advice
look for collaborators and more make
sure to visit
wnb.me paper forum and say hi or just
click the link in the video description
our thanks to weights and biases for
their long-standing support and for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time